So, Izabel, let's brainstorm and come up with the perfect
pizza app for Android. What would your top three features be?
>> My top three features would be
seasonal recommendations. Because I think people like
to order new things all the time
and why not take advantage of seasonal ingredients.
>> Second one?
>> The second thing I would choose would be, a filtered ingredient list.
>> Oh.
>> because some people have food preferences. Like, they can't eat
gluten or they're vegan. So, just remove stuff that they can't
eat, completely off the menu. Just filter it
for them. [CROSSTALK] And third would be Google
Wallet because this is for Android and that's
the primary way people pay for stuff on Android.
>> Oh, it's fantastic.
>> So, what about you, what would your, what do
you think the top three features for this app should be?
>> For me, they're actually a bit different. My number one feature would be
one-click ordering. Cause I think that the
user would really enjoy very quickly ordering
a pizza for the first time and also coming back and
making repeat orders. The second feature I would pick is, order history.
This would allow someone to find out what they placed an
order for before and see how much money they're spending on pizza.
>> Okay.
>> And finally, I think that the user would really
appreciate real time status updates. Because I know that if they're
hungry and they want their pizza delivered, they would want to
know where it is and when it's going to get there.
>> Perfect.
So, looking at these features, it kind of seems
like the three features you picked are classic
you. Because you're a creature of habit, and
you always order the same food every single time.
>> That's true.
>> So you can get back to coding. You think of food as fuel.
>> I do think of food as fuel. Who doesn't?
>> Yes, and order history, you're like super detailed
with your finances so that kind of makes sense for you.
>> That's true. Good point.
>> And status updates. You're always checking like every five
seconds when your packages don't arrive so, you know, I'm noticing
a trend here. That these are, this kind of sounds like the Nazmul pizza app.
>> It does. It's funny you mentioned
that because your features reflect very much
who you are. Like, you are a foodie. You're extremely picky about what you eat.
>> Yes.
>> And so the seasonal recommendations make sense, and also the menu
filtering is a good option for you because you don't like gluten.
>> Yep.
>> And the Google Wallet makes sense, because you are super-fan Android user.
>> Yeah, these features
are kind of classic me.
>> So what are your favorite features, and do
they reflect on who you are? Are they classic you?